Woman 2:
I want a Chevy now.
Woman 3:
I know!
>> Laura: IF YOU'RE A PARENT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE SEXTING
EPIDEMIC IN THE LATEST FROM THE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IS NOT
WELCOME NEWS.
>> A SURPRISING STUDY ABOUT
TEENS AND IT SEXTING IT'S MORE
COMMON THAN YOU THINK IT COULD
BE CAUSING LEGAL TROUBLE.
>> 27% OF KIDS UNDER 18 RECEIVE
SEXT MESSAGES INCLUDING
NUDE PHOTOS.
NEARLY 15% OF TEENS SEND THEM.
>> Laura: THAT'S A
HEARTBREAKER.
AND NOW SOME EXPERTS SAY IT
SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN SEX ED
CLASSES BECAUSE IT'S THE NEW
NORMAL.
LET'S ASK.
LET'S START WITH DR. RUSKIN.
WHEN I READ THE EXPERTS SAY I
USUALLY IGNORE THEM BECAUSE THE
SAME PEOPLE TOLD ME TO DO DUMB
STUFF WHEN I BUILT THE HOUSE AND
THEY WERE WRONG.
SEXTING SHOULD BE NORMAL AND
HEALTHY AND WE SHOULD TEACH IT
IN SEX ED, YOUR REACTION.
>> IT'S A VERY NORMAL PART FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF TEENS TO EXPLORE
SEXUALLY.
SEXTING MEETING UTILIZING YOUR
PHONE TO EXPRESS YOUR THOUGHTS
AND FEELINGS AS PART OF THE
DIGITAL AGE.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHY HAVING SEX
EDUCATION WOULD BE HELPFUL
BECAUSE YOU CAN TALK ABOUT HOW
TO DO IT IN A DIGITAL AGE THAT
IS BEING MINDFUL OF NOT HAVING
SEX EXTORTION.
HAVING NONDIGITAL CENSORSHIP.
I KNOW IT SOUNDS RIDICULOUS.
THERE IS A SAFE SEXTING THAT IS
CONSENSUAL AND THEN THERE IS
NOT.
>> Laura: SEXTING IS
CONSENSUAL, WHAT HAPPENS FOR THE
BIG BREAK UP?
SORRY, THIS IS WHAT SHE SENT ME
AND THEN HE SCREENSHOTS IT AND
THEN YOU'RE OFF TO THE RACES.
THIS IS A NIGHTMARE FOR KIDS.
IT'S A DISASTER FOR YOUNG WOMEN.
>> THAT'S WHY EDUCATION --
>> Laura: HERE'S MY EDUCATION,
YOU'RE IN MY CLASSROOM, HERE'S
IN MY EDUCATION, DON'T SEXT.
>> THEY ARE.
>> YOU POINT TO SOMETHING THAT
HAS BEEN PROVEN BY SCIENCE.
AN ARM OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD NOT
EXACTLY A CONSERVATIVE MEKA HAS
SAID THAT THE MORE YOU TEACH SEX
ED, THE MORE CHILDREN HAVE THE
MORE UNWANTED PREGNANCY AND THE
MORE ABORTION ENDS UP AS A
RESULT.
EVEN MORE RECENTLY, YOU HAVE NEW
RESEARCH THAT SAYS THAT WOMEN
ARE MOSTLY HARMED THROUGH
SEXTING.
NO WONDER KIDS ARE SCREWED UP
TODAY, WHEN PARENTS DO THEIR JOB
THEY TURN OVER TO BIG BROTHER,
THAT IDEA WON'T EVER WORK.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY FOR
BOTH OF YOU A HEART WRENCHING
PIECE OF VIDEOTAPE.
>> BETHANY BERT LOWE WAS IN
HIGH SCHOOL WHEN SHE SENT A
REVEALING SHOT OF HERSELF TO A
BOY SHE WAS DATING BUT IT ENDED
UP IN THE WRONG HANDS.
>> I JUST WANTED TO BE ALONE.
I FELT HORRIBLE.
>> FOR THREE YEARS SHE SAYS SHE
RECEIVED THREATENING MESSAGES AT
DEMANDING SHE SENT MORE EXPLICIT
PHOTOS.
>> I GOT A TEXT THAT SAID I HAVE
SOME PHOTOS OF YOU, IF YOU DON'T
DO WHAT I SAY, YOU'RE GOING TO
REGRET IT.
>> THE PERSON ON THE OTHER END
OF THOSE THREATS A FORMER
CLASSMATE FOUND GUILTY OF
EXPLOITING HER, SHE REMAINS
BEHIND BARS.
>> Laura: THESE ARE KIDS WITH
HER HORMONES RACING.
>> THIS IS WHY WE NEED EDUCATION
TO TALK ABOUT -- SEXTING NEED
NOT BE SENDING PICTURES, IT CAN
BE EXPRESSING YOURSELF WITH
WORDS.
>> Laura: YOU DON'T THINK THE
WORDS CAN BE USED AGAINST YOU?
HOW ABOUT GO ON A DATE AND LOOK
AT EACH OTHER AND TALK TO EACH
OTHER AND GROW UP?
>> THAT TOO.